le département et antenne réunion vous
présente lien social
[Musique]
lutter contre l'insalubrité c'est l'une
des missions de la spla re la société
publique locale à venir réunion cette
entreprise publique intervient chez les
familles en difficulté pour améliorer la
sécurité et l'accessibilité de leur
logement à saint-andré et manulife une
demande l'aide pour réhabiliter la salle
de bain de son père
[Musique]
petite visite de courtoisie pour elodie
elle est technicienne pour la spla la
société publique locale à venir réunion
et elle a suivi le dossier des manuela
et de son père il y a encore quelques
jours la salle de bain et les toilettes
de la maison était peu fonctionnel pour
le fauteuil roulant du propriétaire
emanuela a donc fait appel à l'asp l'art
pour réaménager les pièces
[Musique]
l'asp l'art est une entreprise publique
créée en 2011 par le département
ces missions portent à la fois sur les
projets d'infrastructures de l'île mais
aussi sur l'amélioration de l'habitat
pour les publics prioritaires
nos missions sont celles donc de
l'instruction des demandes
d'amélioration d'habitat pour le pour
les ménages qui sont des personnes âgées
les personnes handicapées ou des
familles d'accueil
accueillant donc de personnes
handicapées ou âgées ou les enfants
nous on fonctionne sur une liste
d'entreprises agréées par le département
donc chez nous dès la demande il y à un
technicien qui est
et qui est mandaté sur place pour faire
un diagnostic un diagnostic des besoins
donc du logement un diagnostic de
2les sur l'éligibilité qui va pas mettre
200 de confirmer l'éligibilité donc du
ménage et des travaux par rapport au
règlement du département chez la famille
flury cours c'est l audi qui s'est
occupé du diagnostic
c'est à ce moment qu'on voit avec la
famille qu'est ce qu'il souhaite mais
man entre temps il ya une semaine qui se
passe ou en fait ils ont tendre et que
je fais assez bien ce qu'ils veulent
la flotte de la visite de vie c'est à ce
moment qu'il est établi ici
les travaux ont duré une semaine pour un
coût total de 6000 euros entièrement
financés pour emanuela qui a entendu
parler de l'asp l'art grâce au bouche à
oreille
c'est un soulagement marc cousine m'a
proposé de faire une demande parce que
vu son état et la salle de bains j'étais
bon d'accord on va faire la demande pour
voir si on peut améliorer parce que moi
je pouvais pas avec les moyens que j'ai
je pouvais pas faire ça
en 2017 plus de 800 dossiers ont été
traités sur toute l'île à la réunion la
question du logement reste un enjeu
social majeur pour les départements
l'habitat de loyauté importante parce
que comment voulez vous qu'une famille
puisse construire son projet de vie si
cette famille vit dans des conditions
d'habitat insalubre et on n'intervient
pas dans une famille comme on peut
intervenir sur les routes par exemple
c'est un vrai métier mais un métier du
social
hélas ce plan a su développer ces corps
de métier où il faut savoir écouter les
personnes en difficulté à voir monter
leur dossier et aussi savoir trouver les
entreprises doit mener à bien les
travaux
mission accomplie chez emmanuel à et son
père qui pourront mieux profiter de la
maison familiale
[Musique]
l'asp l'art est une entreprise publique
créée en 2011 par le département qui est
son principal actionnaire
elle intervient sur des projets
d'infrastructure publique d'entretien
des espaces naturels mais surtout
d'amélioration de l'habitat pour un
public prioritaire
les aides à l'amélioration de l'habitat
s'adresse aux ménages à revenus modestes
aux personnes âgées aux handicapés et
aux familles d'accueil le montant des
travaux subventionnés peut aller jusqu'à
dix mille euros en moyenne et concerne
en priorité des travaux de sécurisation
et d'accessibilité au logement
pour plus de renseignements vous pouvez
consulter le site de la spla au
www.sedar.com
lien social accompagne le réunionnais
pour la mobilité
je m'appelle fontaine et roanne vient du
piton hyacinthe lieu dit du de la plaine
des cafres j'ai 31 ans et
et je bosse ici en tant que charcutier
traiteur à lyon alors et rhône avant de
venir c'était et erwan agriculture donc
rien à voir avec ce que je fais en ce
moment à
je travaille avec mon parrain et mon
papa à la base et c'est grâce à eux
aussi que j'ai quitté la réunion ils
m'ont dit ben vas-y essaye pour voir ce
que ça donne et si c'est vraiment ça ne
paie pas revient n'y a pas de souci
là-dessus mais franchement les vraiment
à tester le cnar ni soutien ou à
s'enfonçant bilan positif sur toute la
longueur du
du début que j'ai quitté la réunion
jusqu'au moment je suis arrivé ici
je commence je me suis installé tout et
du positif pourquoi venir à lyon c'est
pour un changement devient fait
[Musique]